stick
what's up
next because the unwanted rock comes
from get
hey
um
so yeah hey i'm jan van empent i'm going
to talk about dynamic linear algebra and
first i want to briefly explain what
does this dynamic refer to
and for that let's consider a classic
algorithm so usually when we talk about
algorithms we use the following model we
receive some input
then using the algorithm we perform
computations and eventually we receive
an output
but this classic model of computation
can be really inefficient for many
modern scenarios
because what does happen in the real
world
well our input can change over time
let's say you try to analyze a social
network then there are constantly new
friendships forming new users that
register
or maybe you have some routing tasks on
a road network
because of the traffic conditions the
optimal solution can also constantly
change
and if you then just run your algorithm
over and over again constantly
recomputing the solution that's just
going to be really inefficient
that's
why we study dynamic algorithms what we
try to figure out is how can we update
the solution
with as little time as possible
we're trying to find data structures
that are able to maintain the solution
to
well any type of computational problem
and yeah my research focus here is on
dynamic linear algebra so these are
algorithmic techniques that allow us to
efficiently handle
dynamically changing matrices so try to
maintain some property of a matrix where
the matrix is allowed to change over
time
and i use these techniques to answer
open problems in the area of dynamic
graphs
these are dynamic algorithms for graphs
that keep changing things like social
networks or whole networks
and i used these dynamic linear algebra
techniques also in
the area of optimization to speed up a
bunch of optimization algorithms
so let's talk briefly about dynamic
graphs
we already gave the example of social
networks and old networks but we could
also consider for example computer
networks because servers and computers
they might go online or offline or maybe
we create new links or maybe some link
breaks so these networks they are all
constantly changing
and
you can just translate
a graph into a matrix right you just
take the adjacency matrix you know if
you have a dynamic graph let's say
one of these edges is going to be
deleted then this really just means you
have to update your adjacency matrix but
for example a one down there in the
corner zero then the corner when the
edge is deleted
and this way you can translate dynamic
graphs into dynamic matrices
and that actually exists a whole bunch
of reductions that allow you
to phrase graph theoretic problems as an
algebraic problem for matrices
and using these reductions you get a
whole bunch of algorithms for
graph theoretic problems so you don't
need to read all of them i just want to
point out there are a lot of graph
periodic problems which you can solve on
dynamic graphs using dynamic linear
algebra by phrasing these problems as
algebra problems
and besides of these
dynamic graph applications
i used dynamic linear algebra also in
the area of optimization
so this now is not in the dynamic
setting these are now classic algorithms
where you receive the input you perform
the computation then you get the output
and you're done but even though this is
a static model you still have some kind
of dynamic aspects because
typically these optimization algorithms
stay iterative
think of something like newton's method
when in every iteration you have to
solve some linear system in order to
compute your newton step
well
since the argument to your function here
is the current point of your
algorithm
and the point is constantly moving
you have
a dynamic matrix for your hessian and a
dynamic vector for your gradient
so this really is just the dynamic
linear algebra problem because you have
to solve the linear system but the
linear system keeps changing over and
over again
and yeah using dynamic linear algebra
techniques
[Music]
um we're then able to speed up things
like newton steps a bit
so let's talk about some results for
linear programs using this technique
so if you look at something like the
central path method for solving linear
programs
there was a deterministic solver by
vatia back from the 80s
and since then all improvements for
linear programs have been randomized
and recently i showed that okay by using
dynamic linear algebra you can speed up
dynamic and you can speed up linear
program solvers and get a matrix
multiplication time deterministic p
solver
and
let's say you have a linear program
where the two dimensions are quite
different you have n constraints where n
is much larger than the dimension d
then
we have an algorithm that runs in nd
plus d cube time and
let's say the constraints are a lot more
than the dimensions like d square or
more then the complexity is really just
bounded by the first term nd right
and well if you have n constraints in b
dimensions then that's already the input
size that you have to eat anyway so this
is a nearly linear time algorithm
besides of things like central path
you can also apply these techniques to
other iterative algorithms think of
something like the simplex algorithm
whenever you move from one vertex to the
next
you also have to solve a linear system
and the classic implementation of the
simplex algorithm needs something like n
squared time per iteration and we show
all right instead of n squared time you
just need n to the 1.5 time per
iteration
okay
so um
now these are these are all results for
linear programs
obviously you can use them to solve
other
problems so
something like discrete optimal
transport
using these results for linear programs
you get a nearly linear time algorithm
for that
you also get a nearly linear time
algorithm for linear l1 regression
assuming that the number of data points
that you have
is at least d to the 1.5 where you use
the dimension so if you have a lot of
points you can now solve this in nearly
linear time
and you can also apply this to
things like min cost flow by matching
negative weight shortest path these
things can also now be solved in nearly
linear time assuming you have enough
edges in your graph at least roughly
into 1.5
okay
and yeah my motivation for the two
programs here at
simon's is that i'm looking for other
interesting iterative algorithms so if
you have some algorithm in your research
area where you have to repeatedly solve
some linear algebra problem it doesn't
have to be a linear system it can also
be something like let's say compute
leverage to us or something like that
then yeah come talk to me maybe we can
construct some data structures for that
and make the algorithms faster
sorry so summary i study dynamic linear
algebra i use that for dynamic graphs to
solve these graph theoretic problems on
dynamic graphs and you can also use that
in
optimization for iterative algorithms
[Applause]
about what's allowed to change what's
allowed to change um
if you can phrase it as a low rank
change
then it's fine
um if it doesn't change in a low rank
way
then usually
you try
in past research we try to modify the
iterative algorithm a bit so that we can
at least handle low rank approximations
of the change
but in the end it always comes down to
trying to phrase the changes in some low
bank way